speaker today is UNC channel is going to
talk about localization schemes so take
it away
thank you John uh yeah hi everyone
um yeah I would like to thank organizers
for setting this wonderful Workshop
um and I really enjoy the talks and
today I'm going to talk about
localization schemes this is John work
with Rhonda and Elden so I'm going to in
this talk I'm going to
thank you
uh in in this talk I'm going to show you
uh three uh localization schemes and the
motivation is to understand uh the
mixing uh mixing time analysis of global
Dynamics for a different kind of uh
Target distributions and the motivation
for for me at least for me to to start
this uh this work is uh
is this it might be like very natural
for many of you to say that or to
understand the mixing time of global
Dynamics you have to understand this
High dimensional expanders and for for
people from CS background I'm actually
more prone statistic probability
background and for me it's actually more
natural to say that oh it's to
understand the mixing time or for a
standpoint algorithm uh it's it's enough
to understand how some kind of
stochastic process works and and we're
trying to to to to getting from this
angle and say that uh yeah you you it is
it is in in many of this sampling
problems it is efficient to have a good
understanding of some suggested process
and you have a good understanding of the
mixing time so let's set up the problem
we have a Target measure so on the state
space either the Boolean hybrid Cube or
R to the end so n-dimensional space and
we want to draw a sample coming from
this target measure mu and usually you
you cannot just sample directly you have
to design a Markov chain to sample this
uh
iteratively and one of the Markov chain
that works very well in the Boolean cube
is the collaborative Dynamics I think
this has been explained in for example
in a boot camp and quickly those talk
about
hello concave polynomials respect to
Independence so I'm just quickly go
through this and Global Dynamics is kind
of iterative algorithm or at each state
it will move to its neighbor by flipping
ice coordinate EI with a public like
with populated one over n you choose the
index and flip that index and then you
move to that uh coordinate you move to a
new point Y with some probability that
you calculate using your target measure
so that you ensure that uh your your
students your stationary measure of your
Markov chain is the correct Target
measure mu here and we already know this
transition kernel that describes the
probability going from a state X to Y
it's this p x to Y and this will be a
transition kernel of size 2 to the N
times 2 to the end you can think about
this like a matrix two to the N times
two to then and we want to understand
the properties of this transition kernel
for some Target measure and so the
mixing time analysis we try to
understand like given some initial
measure and then you let this transition
kernel apply it for K times and you get
a measure at time T at time K and you
get this measure and you want to
understand uh how large this can need to
be so that your measure at time K is
close to the Target measure
in some total variational distance okay
and so there are many ways to prove the
mixing time of sampling algorithm or
Markov chain uh one dominant way is
actually to prove mixing Time by a
functional analysis so uh
I think in the boot camp we have seen is
that we can Define uh this uh called the
restrict form so Direction form takes in
uh two test functions f and g and then
compute the inner product between I
minus V times F and NG with respect to
the measure mu okay
so if you can prove a fungi type of
inequality for your Markov chain also
called the spectral Gap meaning that if
you can prove that for any test function
f the variance on the major mu times the
coefficient Lambda is upper bounded by
this duration form then you can show
actually this Markov chain has a
variance Decay and so this reversible
means that the microbling satisfied
detail balance condition will have
converge to the correct Target
distribution lazy I just added so that
it's analysis is kind of easier and
easier to show and under this condition
you will be able to show that your mark
option will have some kind of variance
they Decay so apply one step of your
Markov chain the variance actually is
decaying at uh at a rate 1 minus Lambda
so then you apply this Mark option K
times that the variance the case that
one minus Lambda to the power K so uh
you can change this variance Decay and
get some kind of uh Bond on the
guess I'm bound on the KO Divergence
between the measure at the iteration K
and the target measure and that will
lead you to some mixing time of this
form that will depend on the 1 over
Lambda Lambda is the puncture constant
here and then the log on the minimum
value of the initial measure one over
minimum value of the initial measure and
the log 1 over Epsilon Epsilon is the
target target Epsilon total variational
distance you want to achieve so this
works in so um
you can have similar functional
inequality for the entropy you can
Define this modify log sample of
inequality and Define this modified
logos constant by replacing variance
with the entropy and by replacing the
duration form FF with the duration form
F log F and then
uh using this modified logos of belief
inequality we will be able to prove some
Chao Divergence Decay and the mixing
time will depend one over uh row uh one
over this modified log suble if constant
and then the Improvement is this the log
log dependency on the initialization
because instead of variance Decay you
instead of like chi-square Divergence
the K you get K or Divergence Decay and
you gain that kind of extra log there
um okay so uh
uh so now for now we'll focus on like
this proving this kind of functional
inequalities so the problem
to understand
a making time of Markov chain it is
sufficient to prove something like this
but the difficulty is that uh you have a
Target measures on the Boolean hypercube
your transition kernel is of a matrix of
size 2 to the N times two to the N it's
like very large transition kernel
you can see that to understand this the
stronger High inequality if you write
out the matrix it's just trying to
understand the second largest eigenvalue
of your transition kernel but the
problem and this Matrix is like too
large and one two together like to get a
good
a good analysis of the second largest
eigenvalue of p and for product measure
it's usually easy and you can understand
each coordinate independently and then
the main question in uh in the sampling
uh analysis that people ask is like I'm
willing to put some uh assumptions on my
target measure and what kind of
assumptions actually will make it easy
to prove this type of function equality
and what kind of assumptions will make
Global Dynamics mix faster in the
Boolean hypercube
um okay let's take a look at the first
type of assumptions that is now very
famous
it's called the spectral Independence
assumption that is introduced by an
arilio and over escaren in 2020
a Target measure on the Boolean
hypercube is called it does actually in
the independence uh if this pairwise
influence Matrix has operated
non-bounded by Ada so this POS influence
Matrix is defined as coordinate wise at
each coordinate the ijs coordinate is
the probability of
having X J equals to plus one condition
on x i equals plus one minus the
probability of X J equals plus one
condition x i equals to minus one so
it's kind of analyzing the influence of
including the ice coordinator on the
probability of the JS coordinates and
you form this Matrix and compute its uh
uh it's operating domain this is a
spectral Independence and they give us
efficient condition for proving specular
Gap so if you assume that all the
conditionals of this measure condition
means that you not only consider this
original measure mu but you ping or you
condition some of the coordinates you
condition one coordinate you condition
two coordinate you conditions three
coordinates all those condition no
measures are spectral independent then
you you can prove a spectral gap of this
form
uh the spectral Gap the Lambda will be
lower bounded by uh
a product of numbers that will depend on
the spectral Independence constant and
if you take for example if I is the one
then you get some kind of telescopic
product and you will you will have a
polynomial mixing time out of it right
actually linear and here
um you'll get that equals to one
um
okay so that's the previous uh framework
uh one thing they they didn't say in the
paper but actually people later realized
actually this special Independence this
pair-wide information looks scary but
actually the pairwise influence Matrix
condition is just the condition on the
covariance you can actually write in in
a Boolean like you just have a Boolean
density
and you can actually write this pairwise
informations and add identity and you
can have this identity the covariance of
your measure mu is equal to diagonal of
your covariance mu plus this pairwise
influence Matrix plus identity so
assuming that this pair was the
influence Matrix has a spectral
non-bonded by it is roughly equivalent
to assuming that your covariance of the
major is funded by some One Plus data
times the diagonal of your covariance of
the nature so
intuitively it makes sense to put
assumptions on the covariance right so
if you have a measure that on the
Boolean hypercube if the covariance mean
is small means that your measure is very
concentrated and then intuitively it
should be easy for Global Dynamics to
Traverse the uh Traverse this this
measure as long as some is connected but
but we the the Intriguing thing is that
it actually needs assumptions of all the
conditional conditional measures not
only the original major covariance is
small but or when you ping all the
coordinates you need the covariance to
be small
um so if you can yeah we have many
experts here and if you ask people
around you might get different answers
on why they have to put on these
conditions on all the conditionals and
yeah people might say it's like the idea
of trickling down and the idea is
clearly inspired inspired by the high
dimensional expanded literature and it's
one of those local to Global kind of
approved techniques that we have seen
and the second question we want to ask
is like what are other kind of more
principal ways that you can put
assumptions on your target distribution
so that that makes easy to prove the
spectral Gap
okay so now we are going to introduce
localization scheme uh our main point is
to say that uh for not all but many
situations localization schemes give you
a unified way to think about what kind
of assumptions that you need to put on
the target measure so that uh you can
easily prove a spectral gaps so a
localization scheme is just a map from
some measure meal and to some slogastia
process so you want to start some start
the stochastic process from the original
measure mu
and then uh this it's the evolution of
the measure and then you want to make
sure that uh for any set a this mu T of
a
is going to be a Martingale matingo
means that yeah if you condition on the
past up to time pts and then take
expectation it will you will get back
the MU s of day
um
okay yeah so yeah so uh our point is
that yeah if you pick a localization
scheme and you study the evolution of
the variants along the localization
scheme
we put assumptions so that the analysis
of the evolution of the variance go
through and then you will get special
Gap
that looks yeah this this statement
looks quite vague now let me give you
like a concrete example here first
um
so the the first localization scheme we
are going to introduce is this
coordinate by coordinate localization
scheme
so uh you will have a original measure
defined on the Boolean hypercube
your jaw a uniform random permutation of
one to N Get You K1 to KN
and you will have one Jaw from this View
and you define
a Time s
uh time I uh new I is the law of the X
condition on
xk1 xki
the way to think about it is like this
it's usually I think about this way so
at Time Zero
you only have your original measure
right at time one
time one you are going to consider the
law of X the conditioning on the kis
coordinate being fixed the kis
coordinate is a random uh the Ki is a
random variable that can take value one
two three four five two to end right so
you get a
many random measures depending on what
Ki is and what is the value of x k i is
so you will get
like the new one will be here but uh
you will get a 2N number of measures
because you can have uh to Ping to to
fix the N coordinates choose one of the
coordinates and then you can choose the
xki to be plus one or minus one so you
will have two n random measures
and then from any point here you can
continue this process
and you get Mewtwo and Mewtwo again you
from U1 to Mu 2 you have
uh
two and two times the N minus one
different measures random measures
generated here right so the you can
think about the the stochastic process
or the service localization process is a
compact way of describing this Ensemble
of measures that is generated in this
way okay so that makes sense
okay so then the claim is that uh when
you consider
the uh
the special Independence paper
and the reason that they put
data spectral Independence or all
conditionals of mu
is a is that they want to ensure that uh
the variance is conserved or the
variance is conserved approximately
along the coordinate by coordinate
localization in the sense that you want
to show this type of inequality so the
the variance at a time I plus 1 is lower
bounded by some constant times the
variance of time I
um yeah
let me
try to show this and and then you get a
sense of like having this kind of
compact notation of a localization how
does that help
um
yeah
so you want to analyze the evolution of
the variance right so you want to first
introduce the test function
and then introduce some
the mean of the test function
foreign
function
and the inequality you want to prove is
that you want to prove well you want to
show that 1 minus ETA and minus I
expectation of y i
it's lower bonded by
the expectation of y i Plus 1.
so the first thing to observe is that
this MI
is a Martingale
foreign
with respect to the filtration with
respect to the randomness generated by X
K1 to x k i
um
so meaning that
the expectation of m i plus 1 given X K1
to x k i
equals to
Mi okay
second thing to observe we want to
relate this these two variants so it's
natural to think about the law of
total probability for variance right so
the second to observe is that you have
this identity that y i
equals to
am I
right so this this actually uh this
looks uh
scary because all the K1 to KI but you
actually just need to analyze this thing
at the level from I to I plus one and
then think about this type of uh
the law of total probability
in general you have this uh
the variance of a random variable Z you
can write it as the variance of
expectation of Z given X
plus the expectation of variance of Z
given X
so this is this is just a translation
this is just a translation of this by
analyzing the randomness in the uh
x k plus 1 and SK I plus one and using
the marketing go properties then you get
something like this
okay so now
if we want to relate the expectation of
y i to the expectation of y i plus one
uh we need to bond this quantity though
this is the coupon today we need to
analyze
um again this this quantity
uh
looks scary but uh you can think about
if you once you are willing to
but but everything happens at going from
Ice coordinate to a a time I to I plus
one if you're willing to condition on
x k i plus one to some values then
analyzing this quantity is just a kind
of uh like analyzing all the conditional
probabilities and then summing them up
right so I'm going to tell you this
uh
[Music]
additional on X okay I plus one equals
to the JS coordinate
this thing uh yeah the calculation is a
little bit tedious I'm going to just
show you the result but everything
should be uh mechanical
um
foreign
so you can do this calculation by
actually
yeah it's like conditioning more
conditioning more on x k i plus 1 equals
to plus one or equals to minus one and
then you you sum This Together up and
you will get uh
this this formula
and then to get to go from here to here
you will just summing this uh sum this
up
you will get something like expectation
of
sum up over the probability of x
okay I plus one equals to J because the
k i plus one in the construction of the
localization scheme is kind of uh as
long as this KR plus one doesn't pick
any of those the previous ones it can
pick this J freely so then that's for
this this is how this weird one over n
plus I appears and N minus I appears so
this is the probability of Ki picking
this probability and then uh you go from
J not equals to K1 to k n
okay I want to KI
and you sum this uh this thing
from this one
Okay so
when you sum them together it's uh it's
natural to to to put this thing in the
kind of Matrix or vector form and
you get something like one minus NS I
expectation of mu I
completion of new RX
foreign
yeah so actually this thing when it gets
here it gets simplified a little bit and
this di is the
covariance Matrix of mu I
okay let me
now you can see that we want to bond
this quantity using
uh using one y i right so if you can
square this thing then you will get the
variance of y i so what all you need
here is the question type of inequality
foreign
Ty
at the variance of mu I of f coming out
from here and then you have a square of
this thing
of this thing is
you get a copy of the covariance some UI
coming out Tso and d i minus one half
of data
because I I get the cover I get the
covariance MU here some already some
things up I don't need the submu right
here
um
okay so now you can see
uh something that is related to the
spectral Independence condition or this
uh
this variance condition
right this variance condition
for all the cleaning for the for the ice
measure mu I will ensure you to be able
to bond this quantity
so that the the spectral Independence
condition is just saying that this
quantity is one plus one plus Zeta okay
or actually I assume it to be
assuming it to be it that's all
and that is the spectral Independence
condition actually it's uh I yeah I
messed up a little bit so ETA will be
this this will be it I assume this will
be it
goes to one it doesn't equals to only
affect her a little bit but you still
get some polynomial but yeah
anyway uh so the the data won't be is
the it was defined as the uh
the spectral Norm of d by minus 1
covariance on mu I is founded by ETA
let's make it symmetric
um
did I
sorry bi is the diagonal of the
covariance matrix it's a diagonal of the
Lawrence Matrix and you can yeah here
you just need a diagonal yeah this
diagonal inverse times The covariance
Matrix to be bonded and that's exactly
the spectral Independence condition and
once you have this this Bond you have
bonded this
Mi plus 1 minus the Mi Square terms
using uh some ETA times the variance of
f i uh variance of F and then you take
expectation
on both sides you get something like
expectation of f i
it's less than
uh ETA divided by n minus I expectation
of f i
f a y i Plus
expectation of y i plus one
right so then you get exactly this one
minus ETA and minus I
expectation of y i
okay then how do you
you have this uh like this type of
inequality relating the ice variance and
the I plus ones variance and how do you
get a spectral by Gap Bond uh you just
uh
take a product of all these inequalities
and you'll get something like uh
the product of I cos to zero to n minus
2 minus ETA I minus one
equation of y i
expectation of Y is zero so the
expectation of Y zero equals to the
variance of mu of for f
right so
at Time Zero you get original measure
you get the variance of mu F and then
you do the telescopic kind of product
you get a
less than expectation of Y
M minus 1.
and let's look at what happens at time n
minus one and time n and minus one you
have pained or n minus one coordinate
only one coordinate is three oh well if
one only one coordinate is three uh you
run Global Dynamics on it this at time n
minus one will be exactly equals to the
the duration format at this uh
actually you only need to put the
expectation of this
then it's less than the duration form at
the at the beginning yeah
uh yeah this I didn't show but this uh
uh you can show that this duration form
in general will when you apply this
stochastic localization in general will
be a super mattingle and then you can
relate to the original uh the ratio form
and from here you get a fungi inequality
you Bond the variance using the duration
form and the coefficient here is exactly
the coefficient that predicts you via
the spectral Independence
okay uh so my point here is that uh
we didn't use the high dimensional
expander we didn't use this up down work
and if you if you find this proven
mechanical upper you have fixed this
coordinated Local Edition
I'm very happy because my point is that
uh what you actually the the most design
happens in what kind of localization you
decide to apply once you choose your the
localization accordingly by coding a
localization scheme and you you you
analyze the evolution of the variants in
some way and you put conditions so that
the analyze of the variance goes through
and uh and and that's that's the
condition actually usually the condition
you need to prove a mixing time of of
your Markov chain uh
okay so then yeah let's also mention
there are actually there are actually
many uh conditions that people discover
in the literature on uh what are the
conditions you need the situation
conditions you need to prove a mixing
time of global dynamics that I mentioned
some of them you have semi-lock
concavity you have fractional law
concavity entropy Independence I
actually have there aren't many or other
conditions that uh like things like
entropy factorization but I didn't
mention but uh for them for these three
conditions you can think about these
three conditions are the conditions that
that bonds the covariance of the measure
not only for all conditionals but also
for all tool measures
and the the Tilted measures are needed
to uh to to to actually to show
approximate conservation of entropy so
you analyze the evolution of entropy
along the coordinate by coordinate
localization and you will you will
notice that to analyze the evolution of
entropy you not only need the
coordinates but also you need a tilted
measures and and those conditional
sufficient conditions to prove a
modified logarithmic quality
um
okay so now
we want to go beyond this coordinate by
coordinate localization and let's first
take a tour beyond the Boolean Cube
to our end and that's where L dance
first introduced the stochastic
localization and we'll get you get some
inspiration from this stochastic
localization uh you have seen uh in in
nimas talk that yeah the stochastic
Local Edition
is the way to transform measure that is
living in an n-dimensional space
the way that the measure transforms is
that in each coordinate X
it will have satisfied the stochastic
differential equation but you have many
Instagram equations they are slightly
coupled coupled in the way that the the
noise is the same and then the couple
through this this
mean Vector mean of the MU T and um you
can think about this there's like uh you
at infinite decimal time
from T to DT you basically randomly
you multiply your measure
by some randomly tilted linear function
and the random is in this Brownian
motion and
and yeah it looks
scary like this but actually you can get
a extensive form of the measure at time
t
the way to think about this is that you
have
uh your original measure mu X
the new T at time T is just a
multiplication of the original measure
with some gaussian measure the gaussian
measure has variance one over t
so at mu T the measure becomes the more
and more concentrated
but the location of the gaussian is
random the location of gaussian depends
on this CT parameter CT follows some
kind of stability differential equation
has just Randomness here
right so uh then the picture we had that
that that picture still works but uh you
have many more
foreign
still works but you have many more uh
measures to from from zero to Mu DT to
Mu DT plus DT and then yeah you have
many more kind of measures and all the
of this all of this actually are the
original measure times the abduction
measure but they get a little bit more
concentrated and the location of those
random measures are random we know the
distribution of this explicitly but we
yeah each one individually wants
actually are random so you can think
about this way
let me show you a picture quickly so
that
if you haven't seen this
you start with some uniform distribution
and you apply this localization process
then the major gets transformed and you
can see that yeah it gets transformed by
becoming more and more concentrated
eventually it becomes like a
concentrated abortion at somewhere but
the location of That gaussian Is Random
perhaps
okay this stochastic localization
technique is used a lot in high
dimensional probability as a proof
technique and in general this type of
proof technique works like this you want
to show some you are you have some high
dimensional measure mu and you want to
show some high dimensional property of
this High dimensional mu and it's not
easy to show it directly so what you do
is basically transform this major mu by
this stochastic local addition
and hopefully that at hand T the measure
becomes so concentrated that the
gaussian part is so dominant that it is
usually easier to prove that property a
for that transform measure and then all
you need to do is to relate this
property or a of the transform measure
to the original measure and this is
usually done by analyzing those to guess
the differential equations
um so yeah I'm not going to talk about
this in detail but you can take a look
at this survey paper by Eldon in the ICM
proceeding proceeding 2022 that this
property a can be a lot of things can be
either parametric inequality as related
to the Kos conjecture and can be the
concentration of this functions in
gaussian space can be noise for
stability or can be fungal inequalities
and all these things that people try to
use this stochastic localization proofs
to prove this property
like Focus coming back to our problems
focused on sampling
uh we want to show
so this functional inequality is our
property a and the the general kind of
strategy to design the localization
scheme is is to to say that this you
want to prove some probability a but
once you run the process at some time T
and this property a is kind of easier to
prove if this function inequality is
easier to prove and to make the entire
proof work that we actually for example
to prove the ponga inequality we need to
make sure that the approximate
conservation or variance so the variance
behaves well along this stochastic
process
um
okay so this is the picture we had in
our paper so on the left you have a
Markov chain you have some initial
measure and you run uh Markov chain and
you get the measures that step K and K
plus one the functional inequality
approach actually reduced the problem to
saying that you only need to understand
how in each step the variance the case
or like how in each step you can whether
you can prove uh upon inequality
uh in in other problems it's not easy to
prove this fungi inequality directly so
we take out the tool and the
localization gives you a way to take a
detour basically you will transform this
measure mu through this localization
process I put the Red Square here
because when you run these localization
for each mu you will get a process you
get many copies of those like random
copies of this beauty and hopefully it's
easier to show ponga inequality or
variance Decay
ETA for those Transformer measures and
you show this first for the transform
measures and then you need to relate
this left column with the right column
and this is the analysis of the
approximate conservation of variance
along the localization scheme and this
part is usually easy part and usually in
this for those duration forms you
usually have a supermarketing goal and
then you will be able to prove that this
is less than some constant times this
less than constant than this and less
than some cons less than some constant
times this and take this detour and you
will be able to prove it okay
okay let's uh let's take an example on
this easing model uh easy model is a
probability measure you find about a
Boolean cube with some quadratic
hamiltonian so it's proportional to
exponential of X transpose JX and H
transpose x j is the interaction Matrix
and H is the external field
what we show in for the easy model is
the
that if you know
that uh
if you
multiply your original measure by some
negative like quadratic terms here and
some run some tilt uh the title part V
transpose X if you know that the
covariance Matrix of those of measures
of this type are all bounded
then you can provide a modified loss of
constant for Global Dynamics
is in this form
and
for easy model we just shown if you if
if the interaction Matrix J is the
positive semi definite Matrix so with
Operator non-bonded by y one by one half
you can actually show that uh by an
argument from Bob schmittent
22 we can actually Bond The covariance
Matrix of this this type of density with
this and then you can prove a modify log
establish inequality that is one over n
times the constant that only depends on
the operator Norm of the interaction
Matrix
yeah let's uh
talk about this tightness a little bit
so this condition you needed this
interaction Matrix to be less than one
half is tight in general if you consider
the query wise model meaning that your
interaction Matrix is proportional to I
I transpose or or for like everywhere
one Matrix
however there's the open problem that if
people consider those easy models under
the share internship Patcher model
meaning that you take this interaction
Matrix to be some temperature times The
goe Matrix gaussian random Matrix
uh this approach only gets you the first
mixing of global Dynamics up to Beta
equals to one force uh but the
conjecture the phase transition actually
happens at beta less than one so this is
the open problem whether you can show
mixing time of global Dynamics up to
Beta it costs to one uh there are other
algorithm sampling algorithm that is
able to achieve up to Beta equals to one
but for Global Dynamics it's still kind
of open uh you can yeah you can think
about this like our our bounded height
in general because we only use the fact
that operator Norm of J is bonded but
for this SK model you probably need to
use the more information than this
operator Norm is funded by for for those
cultural random Matrix it has a lot of a
little bit more Randomness in this
problem and we will not be able to take
advantage at least in our current proof
and let's take a look what happens when
we apply ldan's stochastic localization
to this uh
easy model so you will take some kind of
control you take a control Matrix CT
that is uh two times the interaction
Matrix and the effect of running the L
dance to classical localization process
on this measure is Multiplied in its
original measure
by some gaussian part the gaussian part
now I choose yet to have the uh uh have
the quadratic part that is the two times
J over 2 that then this just this uh
linearly it accumulates at time T and T
times J is the is the quadratic part and
then you have some random uh linear part
that decides where your measure is
concentrated right so when you apply
this the L dance
localization to easy model
you will get uh this type of measure
and the interesting about this the
measure at time T it is equal to the
original easy model I don't know at Time
Zero is equal to the original easy model
at time t
you actually removed all the
quadratically all the interaction parts
of your easy model and you get back some
kind of product distribution
and this is a key observation in
applying evidence to that civil
correlation here is once you get a
product measure at time T equals to one
uh it's not hard to show the modifier
logos of belief inequality
and then
if you think about that diagram
yeah so this side is easy once you get
to time equals to one you get a product
now it's just that easy and all you have
to do is to show some approximate
conservation of variants or apartment
conservation of entropy
so uh
so yeah this part is is scary but you
just take derivative actually you you
take your
uh entropy
of some test function with respect to
measure at time t
uh you take derivative and usually we'll
have some uh terms that depend on like
some term determine sometimes on DT and
some Martin gold terms that only depend
on the brand new motion part uh
and then you want to study the evolution
of the entropy basically you want to
bond this term that appear in the
calculation using the entropy and turns
out that if you can Bond
the covariance of
NATO measure
native measure by some
some constant
Matrix 80 then you can bond this you can
relate this thing that appear in the
stochastic differential equation with
the entropy and then you get a equation
that is only on entropy of new TN you
will be able to lower bound the entropy
solving this equation lower bound the
entropy in some way so you can see that
in again in this thing in this case I
highlight this red condition this red
condition
is needed in this theorem as needed in
this room and we need this red condition
because we want when we study this
evolution of entropy we want this
evolution of entropy you can have
approximate a conservation of entropy
and for this to go through you need to
bond something that sometimes that
appear in the store that's a
differential equation then and you put
assumptions for this to go through
basically
um
okay so so that's yeah that's a picture
for approximate conservation of entropy
uh
here you replace the variance quantity
with the entropy quantities
um
okay I'll just briefly I only have like
five minutes I've just briefly talk
about the third localization scheme that
might be interesting for some of your
applications so the third example we're
going to consider is the this hardcore
model so this hard more core model is
again a measure on the Boolean hypercube
and a country regulation stigma
has positive value if it's supported on
some independent set of a graph and its
density is proportional to Lambda the
fugacity parameter to the size of the
independent set
and so in this graph yeah you can see
that the red ones that I draw all the
independent sets here
the the interesting thing about this
model that is that the the row of plus
one and minus one they are not symmetric
somehow yeah putting a
putting a vertices to be read
has much more influence on on its
neighbor Neighbors than putting
operators to be to be white right so
somehow you want to design a stogacy
process that uh so you want to
understand the mixing time of global
Dynamics for this hardcore model and
somehow you want to design a stogacious
process that is not symmetric for plus
one minus one take advantage of this uh
not Symmetry and so
our we are going to introduce this
negative Fields local addition it's kind
of inspired then by Fields Dynamics in
this channel in and John 2021 paper this
process
uh transform the measure you can still
think about it's kind of some kind of
linear key or to measure at each
infinite decimal time from s to S Plus
DS it is multiplying your original
measure by some random quantity that is
linear in X and instead of having some
Brownian motion noise here you actually
replace it with some uh some centered
person process so this minus DS is the
playing the purpose of centering the
process but this part you will have some
kind of person process but still yeah
this part this this this equation looks
scary but you actually have a simple
interpretation of this this process if
you define
the set 80 is where the coordinates the
the uh the the poisson process one
process has taken value larger than
equal to one so the person process has
has fired or yeah
um
this 80 is an almost really
non-decreasing process of the subsets
and you can actually write the measure
at time t
as a combination of a random restriction
and the tilts so this measure
that I introduced as the stochastic
equation you can write in this short
form that a Time key you will pick a
some
set of 80 that you
paint the coordinates to plus one
condition on those coordinates plus one
and then the measure is tilted towards
minus one with this amount of T of minus
t or one tilt
okay yeah so
this smell yo so the thing to observe
here that this uh this uh negative field
localization process cheats the minus
one and plus one differently right you
will ping some coordinates one but you
also till the measure to minus one so
that you remain a marking go and and you
cannot treat the the plus ones more
seriously and it turns out it's kind of
enough to analyze the mixing time of
global Dynamics for uh sampling the
hardcore model and I don't have time to
show this but uh so you you need two
things to make uh this framework work
localization scheme framework work you
need like for for large time you need
the mixing time analysis is easy or like
so it's easy to prove or modify log
server left inequality and so it's it's
actually known in this airbar Henderson
men's and hetali paper that if you have
a very large tilt for this hardcore
model you can prove a modify logs or the
phone equality for Global Dynamics
easily
and then the second thing in our
analysis you need to analyze the
evolution of the entropy and
yeah so
you will yeah the mechanical thing is
that you just write down the entropy and
take derivative and see what kind of
properties of the hardcore model will
allow you to bond the things up here
that in the derivative and allow you to
prove the evolution of the entropy
um
okay so that's that's it I'm not going
to show the proof and you can take a
look at our paper as a I mean there
there's still a lot of work
even though you're trying to make this
thing mechanical but there's still a lot
of work trying to take advantage of the
property of the hardcore model so that
the evolution of the entropy becomes
easy to analyze okay to summarize uh we
introduced this localization schemes as
a way to analyze the mixing time of
sampling algorithms on Boolean hypercube
or in uh in our end and
we're trying to we're trying to say that
yeah there's this high level thing of
Designing a localization scheme and
there's all this small mechanical part
of proving the evolution of the variants
that works well along the stochastic
localization process and and usually
like we can summarize many of the
assumptions that in the literature to
this Assumption of actually approximate
conservation of variants or entropy
along the localization process and some
of the results yeah we can recover some
of results of spectral Independence and
fractional law concavity we have this
bond for Global Dynamics for easy model
in a unique regime under any external
fields and we have
bonds of global Dynamics from mixing of
Hardcore model industry uniqueness
regime and that's it
[Applause]
any questions
of this
generalized to other Central algorithms
and uh Dynamics uh yes that's uh that's
a good point so if you look at that
diagram
the background doesn't specify which
sampling algorithm you use but you
actually need a summary algorithm to
work well for the transponder measure so
as long as you can prove the sampling
algorithm works well for the transform
measure and you will make this this
diagram work and this part and this part
are usually are not very dependent on
the on the sampling algorithm you use
even though Aston state is honest to be
honest that we didn't try any other
sampling algorithms yeah
so you mentioned this results on Isaac
models
bounded
interactions there with this spectrum of
the vanity
the spectrum of this interaction with
Matrix is standard so there were some
earlier results by Eldon Kohler and say
tuni that got the same variance found
and uh some and later we got the same
entropy bound but those results don't
require the covariance
so require direct interaction Direct
Control and the covariance of the
intermediate things
so can you comment a little bit on
like so you somehow reduce the problem
to learning the covariances but without
somehow don't need it could you comment
a little bit on
why do you think this is needed ah yeah
that's a good point yeah so for this
particular example of easy mode or
somehow you can Bond the yeah the
covariance throughout the process and we
take advantage of that you're saying
your previous work you you don't really
need you still need it for the paintings
right or so somehow these words always
reduce the interaction Matrix to a rank
yes then then they then they use like
known results for the quantity but in
your case you want the direct control
and the covariance of the intermediate
right uh what did you what yeah I don't
remember exactly what do you need you
you also run a stock actually process so
that you can reduce to a rank one uh
measure right it's it's it's a different
stochastic Corporation process yeah yeah
you need some kind of rank n minus one
so that's an organization process to
reduce for that and that part is without
assumption or that part is without
assumption J
sorry
yeah I have to think about that more
carefully but yeah
thanks for the question yeah
any more questions
can someone use the foreign
[Music]
do you have any kind of examples where
that you yeah only need that stuff you
only have some part of the covariance
bondage but yeah it's a very good
question the ideally you want to also
like simplify those those attribution
conditions to prove special balance on
but yeah maybe in some cases you don't
need all the
okay
let's take any further questions of fire
and let's Thank You Beyonce again
[Applause]
we'll turn it two after lunch